david he was fired five six five or six
days before his fifth year anniversary
where
he was promised a bump in severance from
12 months to 18 months so he refused to
sign a severance
and we filed a lawsuit
under title vii and under state law
saying that it was race and gender
discrimination to to be doing this to be
firing people for the purpose of
creating diversity uh david came to
noeman in 2013 to run their marketing
and communications program he rebuilt
the team by all everyone's
both by written and sort of uh the
verbal
acclimation everyone thought he'd done a
great job they won several awards um
and then 2015 the board the uh
the ceo of novant signed on to an
american hospital association
uh
health equity pledge and as a result of
that they
elevated the position of diversity
inclusion officer and that person came
in and presented a plan that the jury
saw
that between 2016 and 18 they were going
to increase
the diversity of the senior leader and
executive leadership teams
david at the beginning of the year his
boss had seven white male
direct reports and by the end of the
year he had two the irony is he was on
the team
executive team that oversaw the plan
and he had no clue that they were going
to turn around and start firing people
just to be able to sort of meet their
goals all that you know there was just
no real justification for his
termination he'd been doing a very good
job and they tried to make up some
concerns about the fact that he'd had
stumbled at a speech two years before
when he felt sick and that embarrassed
the company they said that he was he
lacked engagement but he had some of the
highest engagement scores in the company
and his scores was far his score was far
higher than the person who fired him
um and then they said he didn't engage
with his peers but in his evaluation it
said that was the thing he did best
um so there was all this you know sort
of everything that they came up with we
were able to show just didn't make any
sense and i think the jury just was you
got to be kidding me these explanations
for his termination were nonsense and
they agreed and i think one reason that
they gave the punitive damage award was
just that you just can't fire people to
achieve these sort of demographic goals